Selamlar sevgiler kanalıma hoş geldiniz
Ben Deniz Hoca 9 sınıflarla ilgili
çalışmalarımız kaldığı yerden devam
ediyor bu dersimizde metinlerin
sınıflandırması tablosuna bir göz
atacağız sonra kitapta da geçtiği üzere
öğretici Metinlerle edebi metinlerin
arasındaki farklara bakacağız önemli bir
konu dikkatlice dinliyorsun Hem bu
sınavlar için hem de bundan sonra 10 11
12 sınıfla yine karşına çıkacak hep
karşına çıkacak Çünkü temel bir konu o
yüzden şimdi halledeceğiz bir daha
aklına herhangi bir soru işareti
kalmamış olacak mükemmel bir dste
hazırsan başlıyoruz ve şunu unutma Deniz
Hoca kanalından bir isim olarak
buradasın ama biz bu isimden Büyülü Bir
hikaye oluşturacağız bu hikaye senin
başarı Hikayen olacak Hadi gel bakalım
sözcükten hikayeye dönüşme dileğiyle
dersimiz başlasın Senin de Hikayen
başlasın Evet şimdi metinlerin
Sınıflandırmasını Aslında biz genel
anlamda böyle sınıflandırıyoruz ama
şöyle gel metin nedir neden
sınıflandırılır buna bir göz atalım
şimdi Metin dil aracılığıyla bir araya
getirilmiş anlamlı kelimeler ya da
cümleler toplu olarak ifade edilebilir
Yani sen kelimeleri yan yana koydun
cümleler oluşturdun Bu cümleler geldi
kendi içerisinde bir anlamsal bütün
oluşturdu biz buna genel olarak ne deriz
Evet Metin deriz Bunda bir problem yok
ve insanın kendini ifade etme gücünün
gelişmesi çeşitli tarzlarda oluşturulan
yazılarla birlikte biz bu metinlerin
birbirinden ayrıldığını görüyoruz Çünkü
her metnin amacı farklıdır oluşturma
tarzı farklıdır Dolayısıyla bu
farklılıklar sonucunda Biz metinleri bir
tablo halinde sınıflandırıyoruz edebiyat
eserlerinin biçimlerine teknik
özelliklerine ve Konularına göre
ayrıldığı çeşitlere de tür diyoruz ama
en başta Tabii ki metinlere bakacak
olursak bir sözlü metinler 2 yazılı
metinler olarak ayırabiliriz ama biz
daha çok yazılı Metin kısmına
odaklanacağız hemen şöyle bir tablomuz
gelsin şimdi sözlü kısmına girmeyeceğim
Kafanı karıştırmak istemiyorum şu yazılı
kısma odaklanalım Şimdi biz metinleri
Aslında iki ana başlıkla topluyoruz bir
edebi metinler iki öğretici metinler
edebi metinlerin bir diğer adı unutma
sanatsal metinlerdir Yani buradan
Aslında biz bu metinleri nasıl bir
özelliğe sahip olduğunu az çok
anlayabiliyoruz Peki öğretici metinlerin
ne gibi amacı vardır bak öğretmek bilgi
vermek gibi bir amaç yok mu Evet yani
edebi metinlerde amaç sanat yapmaktır
ama Öğretici metinlerde amaç bilgi
vermektir bir şeyi öğretmektir adından
da alıyoruz Öğretim metinler kendi
içerisinde beşe ayrılır 1 tarihi
metinler 2 felsefe metinler 3 bilimsel
metinler 4 kişisel hayatı konu alan 5
ise gazete çevresinde oluşan metinler
daha çok biz Şunlara odaklanacağız
mesela kişisel hayatı konu alan yani
merkezinde bir insanın yer aldığı metin
türünden bahsediyorum Hani anıları
gördük değil mi Bu dönem gördüğümüz bir
konu İşte o sonuç itibariyle bir insan
Merkezi oluşturulduğu için kişisel
hayatı konu alan bir metin türüdür
öğretici metin türüdür Bununla birlikte
Mektup günlük biyografi otobiyografi
gezi yazısı bunların hepsinin merkezinde
kim vardır kişi vardır kişinin kendisi
vardır O yüzden biz bunlara kişisel
hayatı konu alan metinler diyoruz Bir de
gazete çevresine gelişen oluşan metinler
vardır Bunlar da varlıklarını gazeteye
borçludur mesela eleştiri makale deneme
fıkra fıkra dediğimiz köşe yazısıdır e
haber yazısı sohbet röportaj mülakat
Bunlar da gazete çevresinde oluşan
öğretici metinlerdir Şimdi gelelim biz
Sanatsal metin yani öğretici metin
kısmına o da kendi içerisinde ikiye
ayrılıyor bir coşku ve heyecan dile
getiren metinler yani şiirlerden
bahsediyorum ki bundan sonraki derslerde
göreceğiz Şiir nedir Bunu yakından
tanıyacağız bir diğeri ise olay iç
çevresinde gelişen metinler Yani bir
olay anlatan mesela Roman olay anlatmaz
mı hikaye olay anlatmaz mı tiyatro
anlatmaz mı hayır anlatmaz gösterir ama
sonuçta merkezinde ne vardır olay vardır
şimdi olay çevresinde gelişen metinlere
şöyle yakından göz atacağız onu da kendi
içerisinde ikiye ayıracağız bir
anlatmaya bağlı yani bir olay var Sen bu
olayı görüyorsun ve başkasına aktarmaya
çalışıyorsun iki göstermeye bağlı şimdi
göstermeye bağlanan kasıt aslında
tiyatrodur Sadece tiyatroyu bilil alt
başlıklarını Şimdilik bilmesen de olur
yani geleneksel tiyatro modern tiyatro
Bunlar Şimdi senin konun değil sen edebi
metinlerin Göstermeye ve anlatmaya bağlı
olarak ikiye ayrıldığını unutma ve
göstermeye bağlı metinlerden kastımız da
tiyatro olduğunu şu anda aklında tut bu
yeter ama gelelim anlatmaya bağlı
metinler Yani bir olay var Bunu gören
birisi var bir anlatıcı var bu olayları
ne yapıyor sana anlatıyor Bunlar nedir
bunlar fabır masaldır halk hikayesidir
hikayedir romandır destandır manzum
hikaye mesnevidir Çünkü bunların hepsi
ne yapar bir olay anlatır Hepsi de anlat
anlatmaya bağlı metinler kategorisinde
yer alır unutma Şimdi şu metinlerin
sınıflandırma tablosunu gördük Hatta
şuradan da bakabilirsin bak ikiye
ayırıyoruz bir sanat metinleri iki
Öğretim metinler öğretici metinleri
kendi içerisinde beşe ayırıyoruz ki şu
tabloda zaten ayırdık sanat metinlerini
de ikiye ayırıyoruz olay ve Coşku
heyecanı dile getiren metinler diğeri de
olay çevresinde gelişen metinlerde bu
olay çevresinde gelişen metinleri kendi
içerisinde Göstermeye ve anlatmaya bağlı
olarak ikiye ayırıyoruz Aslında olay bu
Peki bunların ne gibi özellikleri var
Gel bakalım Mesela edebi metinlerin ne
gibi özelliği var siz hikayeyi gördünüz
değil mi Bundan sonra şiiri göreceksiniz
Onun dışında anıyı gördünüz ve de başka
metin türlerini de göreceksiniz mesela
mülakatı da gördünüz Ne bileyim buna
benzer öğreti metinleri de göreceksiniz
şimdi gel özelliklerine bakalım bir kere
edebi metinlerinin En temel özelliği
estetik heyecan uyandırması yani estetik
nedir güzellik demektir değil mi Yani
bir metnin amacı Edebi metnin amacı
Aslında sen de bir güzellik duygusu
uyandırabilir O yüzden ne diyoruz
birinci özelliğimiz muhatabına estetik
bir heyecan uyandırır diyoruz 2 doğrudan
bilgilendirme amacı taşımaz yani amaç
doğrudan bilgi vermek değildir Tabii ki
dolaylı olarak bir bilgi edinebilirsin
oradan ama temel amacımız kesinlikle Ya
ben bir roman yazayım bir hikaye yazayım
Ahmet Ayşe bundan ders çıkarsın değildir
amaç estetik bir ürün okunabilecek
insanlar hoşuna gidebilecek bir ürün
oluşturabilmek temel amaç budur 3 günlük
dilden farklı olarak edebi bir dile
sahiptir yani kelimeler yan ve mecaz
anlamlarla bezenmiştir O yüzden ne
diyoruz çok anlamlılık söz konusudur
belki de en önemli özelliklerden bir
tanesi budur yan ve mecaz anlamlarla
bezenmiştir yani sözcükler gerçek
anlamda değil yan ya da mecaz anlamda
kullanılır Dolayısıyla Oka göre farklı
anlamlar çıkarılabilir O yüzden ne
diyoruz çok anlamlılık söz konusudur e
Bununla birlikte öznellik söz konusudur
yani nesnel değildir öznel bir bakış
açısıyla oluşturulur estetik bir
kaygıyla yazılır Bunu zaten belirttik
mecazlı anlatıma başvurulur özel bir
iletişim aracıdır Çünkü yaratıldığı dili
topluluğu yansıtır bir şekilde iletişim
kurar toplum arasında böyle bir yönü de
vardır ve en önemli özelliklerden bir
tanesi de kurmaca bir yapıya sahiptir
yani edebi metinlerde gerçeklik değil
kurmaca bir gerçeklik vardır hani
hatırlıyor musunuz ders kitaplarınız da
var anılarla hikaye arasındaki farkları
söyleyeyim diyorlar ya ilk başta yazman
gereken şey şu sınavda da karşına
çıkacaktır ama sana puan aldıracak kilit
cümle şu bir kere hikayeler kurguları
anlatır yani orada bir gerçeklik
olabilir ama bu gerçeklik unutma
kurgusal bir gerçektir kurgulanmıştır
oradaki gerçekler Ama anıda gerçekler
yaşanmışlıklar Özellikle bu
yaşanmışlıklar ifadesini kullanın ön
plandadır Dolayısıyla arasındaki en
büyük fark da budur bunu da görmüş olduk
Peki öğretici metinlerin ne gibi amacı
vardır bir kere Bilgi verme amaçlıdır
bilgi verir nesnel bilgilere yer verir
yani edebi metinler özneli kişiden
kişiye değişebilirdi Ama bu Hayır nesnel
bilgilere yer verir 2 + 2 4 bitti Su 100
derecede kaynar deniz seviyesinde bitti
aksi söylenemez nesnel herkes için
geçerli Bunun dışında başka bir şey
düşünemez işte böyle bir özellik söz
konusudur kelimeler gerçek anlamıyla
kullanılır ama neydi edebi metinlerde
yan ve mecaz anlamlı kullanılırdı burada
unutmayacaksın gerçek anlamda kullanılır
tanımlar yer zaman miktar gibi somut ve
kesin bilgiler içerir kesinlik vardır
anlatıcı nesnel bir tutum izler ama ne
dedik ede metinde özneldir burada nesnel
olmak zorunda sade ve cümleler kısa
olmalı yani anlatımın herkes için
anlaşılır olması lazımdı Peki ede
metinler öyle mi Bak ede metinler mesela
Şiir dili açık olabilir ama yan ve mecaz
anlamlılık söz konusu olduğundan ağır
bastığından okuyanlar farklı yorumlar
Yani sen bir şiiri Okuduğun zaman farklı
yorumlarsınız farklı yorumlarım Ahmet
Ayşa okuduğu zaman farklı yorumlar ama
öğretici metinler öyle değildir okuyan
herkes aynı şeyi anlar en temel
farklardan bir tanesi budur Burada da
böyle bir özellik söz konusu terimler ve
teknik kelimeler yoğun olarak kullanılır
söz sanatlarına kesinlikle başvurulmaz
anlatım açık ve net olmak zorunda
kurmaca söz konusu değildir gerçekler
vardı tamam mı gerçekler dile getir en
önemli özelliklerden bir tanesi de buydu
Hadi şimdi gel bu iki Metin türünün
farklılığını bir tablo halinde görelim
Bak şimdi ne diyoruz biz edebi metinler
için gerçeklik açısından alacak olursak
ele diyeceğiz ki kurgusal bir gerçeklik
vardı yani edebi metinlerde gerçekler
yok kurgular vardır bunu unutmayacaksın
ama Öğretici metinlerde gerçekler vardır
unutma amaç olarak bakacak olursak edebi
metinlerin amacı neydi estetik zevk
vermekte ama Öğretim metinlerin amacı
adından da anlıyoruz bak bilgi vermek
öğretmek zaten ismimizi bize ipucu
veriyor değil mi edebi metinler bir
diğer ismiyle sanat metinleri sanat
metinleri estetik bir zevk verir sanat
yapmayı amaçlar ama Öğretim metinler
adından da anlıyoruz öğretmek bilgi
vermek ister bu da Zaten mantıken
anlayabileceğimiz bir özellik ya da
karşılaştırma Peki üslup açısından
bakalım şimdi edebi metinlerde mesela
şiiri düşünün son derece süslü bir
anlatım tarzı vardır üslup süslüdür
tamam mı Ama burada yani Öğretim Metin
nerde süslü üslup olamaz sade bir üslup
olmalı Neden Çünkü amaç herkese o bilgi
aktarmak amaç öğretmek Zaten amaç
öğretmez Benim dilim anlatımın süslü
olabilir mi olamaz Tabii ki bu mantığa
aykırı Peki anlatım olarak bakalım şimdi
özneldir diyeceğiz edebi metinler ama
öğretici metinler ise unutma nesneldir
ancak anlamsal olarak bakacak olursak
edebi metinlerde yan ve mecaz anlamlar
ağır basar ama öğreti metinler gerçek
anlamlıdır unutmayacaksın Dolayısıyla
Edim metinlerde çok anlamlılık söz
konusu ama Öğreti metinlerde tek
anlamlılık söz konusu Bu da önemli
farklı şu tabloyu mutlaka resmini çek
aklına bulunsun Ama zaten ben ne
yapacağım Bu slaytı bu bilgileri bu
pdf'i Ben videonun açıklam kısmında link
olarak ekleyeceğim Oradan da
indirebilirsiniz her zaman
kullanabilirsiniz her şey tüm pdf'ler
ücretsiz olarak Deniz Hoca kanalında her
videonun altında yer alıyor Sen de
bunlardan faydalanmayı unutma Evet bugün
öğretici Metinlerle edebi metinleri
gördük metinlerin sınıflandırması
tablosuna göz attık önemliydi Bu temada
ikinci temada karşımıza çıkan bir
bilgiyi en doğru en sade bilgiyi Bu
videoda sana aktardım senin için çok çok
faydalı olacak yine sınavda hedefimiz
neydi ydü 100 almak bunun için çalışmaya
devam ediyoruz Yeni konular gelecek
Takipte kal ama dokun sınıf WhatsApp
kanalımız var oraya gel ki bu
bildirimleri kaçırma Bu bir aynı zamanda
bu Videoyu beğen kanalıma abone ol ve
Lütfen düşüncelerini yorum olarak
paylaşmayı unutma Sevgiyle kal Hoşça kal
görüşürüz